teenee let me ask you the old poll
question would you rather be a backup
quarterback or an all-pro kicker Wow a
backup quarterback it depends on what
team you're talking about they're
probably an all-pro kick yeah I may be
the kicker yeah because I could have you
as a backup quarterback for the Broncos
with Peyton Manning but you're not going
to see any playing time no but I want us
to grow yeah and they are you judged
even their Super Bowl as a kicker
I'll make it up ok ok let's say you
could be on a military or any backup
quarterback I'm Adams fans down not even
close
like were you a special teams guy when
you first got in the link yeah yeah well
I was well yes and no I wasn't on I was
listed as a special teams guy but I
wasn't actively doing anything I was
kind of like fifth or sixth behind you
know a lot of guys and I would get few
reps at you know as a special teams
player but I played it in high school I
was actually kicker in high school I
kicked off and ran down the mane-iac you
know then when I was in Pop Warner I got
punted the ball so I kind of played a
lot of different positions throughout my
my life but no I wasn't just I wasn't
just a special teams player I did do
some of it though but pre-season
training camp was really important for
you considering where you were drafted
where as I look at Lady on bail not
being in camp and I wonder the
importance of camp for running back who
is one of the better running backs
established there does it matter that
Le'Veon Bell is not in training camp in
your opinion well I'd like to think it
does matter and it's not from just a
physical standpoint of him doing you
know game reps or nothing to practice
reps help and I know people look at
Adrian Peterson vote for a number of
years or LaDainian Tomlinson they didn't
play in the preseason
okay
practice and so I think the practice
time that is missing is is it invaluable
and I'm not wanting to believe that you
know that you can throw away practice
reps and it's like okay I don't really
need them I'm going to come come in and
be mode so if and I think from a
condition standpoint gain speed and gain
conditioning is totally different
hmm if you can get those in practice not
think it helps you to gain okay I think
eventually becomes in obviously you know
maybe it's three or four weeks we'll
catch up but the early time I think he's
going to struggle
what about Ezekiel Elliott first of all
the Cowboys in replacing him with
McFadden or Morris and that offensive
line is great but I'm wondering what the
residual effect
Fiona be on dak Prescott it is dak
Prescott going to be asked or forced to
do more with Elliot perhaps not being in
there for those six games I think he is
and if you know I've seen McFadden and
you know we saw his last game and I
think he still has enough in the
paintings to hold down a six-game
stretch and human and Morris and you
know maybe is Rocksmith they started to
have enough to have a magician running
game I don't think it's going to be
explosive like when when Zeke is in
there but I think it's going to be
decent enough to where they they have
someone somebody game but I think that
is going to have to do a little bit more
doing a six-game stretch he has to you
know in training camp he says that he
wanted more on its plate and I think
he's going to chancing is that because
if he thinks it's just or accountable
you think they're just going to roll out
the same offense and have him be you
know pretty much conservative and
protected football last year with him
that was kind of like a putt with a good
play for important for the Cowboys and I
went back and watched tape on them and
it was a few throws where I saw that he
could have probably forced the ball in
and it could have been a big play or
could have been a pick and I think this
year he has to take that chance to make
them that's the role and that's when you
you start to be a little bit more risky
you know high-risk high-reward
for him and I see that happened its
first six teams and I think that uh you
know you guys you just got one and
Jason there you've got it you've got to
test a little bit ball because that oh
and the ball off the disease or that the
interstates come down for Morrison in
the Clanton I don't know how far this
goes Mitch if you don't have to take
some risk that offers early the
defense's want to get a larger sample
size with quarterbacks like the second
time around or the second year that's
when defense is adjust to you they get
your tendencies but I'm curious as a
running back did defenses kick up on
tendencies certain things you'd like to
do or you didn't do as well and try to
force you into those things oh you know
yes that's that's the name of the game
and if you are a a good defensive
coordinator you have to try to make
somebody beat you at someone that
they're not strong at doing and you know
what the counter is you've got a one
thing I would try to work on there's
things that I felt I was not very good
at whether it was past blocking or
catching the ball out of the backfield
whether it was a certain runs like drawl
I wasn't a big draw play think I've got
but you know I would work on that stuff
so that I try not to have any visible
weaknesses and as an office we would try
to do that we would try to change things
up personality and different formations
and stuff like that to try to tell
people also they couldn't hone in on
what we did extremely well but you
notice it's a cat now State that's
really what it is is played every year
and then displayed every game and the
coaches were able to help to figure it
out are the ones who seem to be on top
over here Terrell Davis Broncos Hall of
Famer joining us where's the gold jacket
right now man man it's uh it's in a
closet man but it's a little it's a
little little smelly right now that I
would take a good refresher go a ward
out so it was at a party and a banana
loaf about seven days straight man it's
you may not be laying down what's good
about it though that it's a nice light
fabric nice oh it's not really heavy in
it it airs out pretty good but I need to
go take it they clean up they can have
some part of your party stains on it
think of your bust oh I love the bust I
love this man my wife she was really the
one behind it she kind of helped a guy
had been who was doing it when he came
to see me
we were in a hotel for like eight hours
and my wife came over it and immediately
she walked in she looked at it and she's
like Nana was good I said but cuz it's
just something I write and so she just
like went to work with her eyes and kind
of helped walking through baby was
already he was pretty good but she was
into working together and then my mom we
syndicate my mom but kind of picked some
pictures and said hey take a look at
this and tell it tell us what you think
and she made some comment about some
stuff and so yeah I wanted when it was
all said and done I was uh I'm pleased
with it yeah looks good else he said he
didn't know what the question is what
you think I thought yours looked great
but but you got a great head hey y'all
my beds in my hair I think that it was
here to get all like the imperfections
he stuff the undulations on my own
eldest mary i thought it looked good LT
said he didn't smile because he said you
don't look good your teeth don't look
good in that bronze so did you factor
that in well that's what they told well
yeah factor them because that's what Ben
had codeword me he said you asked me how
did I want it and I said you know I said
I wanted a pleasant you know smile and
he said it's gonna be the heads up that
you really don't want to do of teeth
showing said why said because it's hard
it's so hard to make it look good and he
says I just you know recommend teeth and
so I said okay now so just have it with
a pleasant smile I don't want to I don't
want to look beat you know about a
because of liner and or my impact I said
just have a pleasant little little smile
and so yeah that's what he did that's
John Elway story I haven't heard there's
John Elway story I don't know what sort
of you've heard of you or you haven't
give me a give me one that you'll tell
your grandkids
oh my grandkids not I don't know I think
I don't know I mean what a story would
be the person would the first time that
I was in the huddle of John Hill John
Elway was um you know God took a handoff
from women everything is I had one
previous with God and into the first
week they announced that I was going to
be a starter that morning we walked up
to practice and I'm nervous as hell
because John's in the huddle and I have
to turn up his trust and we get a first
call with someone to the left and I took
off and I remember John came back and he
gave me to the ball I thought the ball
was a little high but I kind of bobbled
it and I was fumbled it and so you know
we kind of had a botched exchange and I
just you know kind of gather the ball
and finish the run and on my way back I
saw John talking to Gary Kubiak and John
walks back to the huddle and crew calls
me over and hey John says you need to
give him a bigger pocket and I'm
thinking oh oh like you know a lot even
so much Han so I've already messed this
thing up man and so uh that was just you
know something came back in and
obviously you know things worked out but
I was kind of nervous that day I'm
thinking man the man is so big that he
usually land messages through other
people you know he doesn't even want to
talk to me that's how big he was never
yelling done oh yeah oh yeah yeah yelled
at me one time with we were playing a
game and it gave it really matters the
last game of the year in San Diego it
was a 96 and we already clinched
everything and I was just we were only
gonna be in there for about a quarter
and it would check out kind of turn
around and got the me the ball and I
drop it and he just yelled at me and I
was thinking man we only plan a quarter
of our life like it doesn't even count
we're just shows how intense he is man
when you gonna feel expects you know
perfection expected to play well and no
kind of got my my thinking up and how I
had to approach the game well congrats
on the Hall of Fame obviously and well
deserved and hope it was everything he
thought it was going to be and more dad
it was it was all so bad
I appreciate the you know everybody to
another love and support for me man I
have can't start some idiot
and people who are homemade responsible
so what to amaze obviously and everybody
off that I think on that this page that
night appreciate it thank you 12
we appreciate it okay that's a thrill
Davis NFL Network analyst the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience